so I want some move to motivate us about
learning these few extensions right
before you are asked me what they are as
an example right
when you've got things in - yup okay
different angles or different function
that kind of thing so far with tree
we've learned that you can't really muck
around with that you kind of see for
instance you can't just divide through
by N and you don't get six or something
like that
okay so we're there trouble working with
remember this is called on this inside
thing no so I've told you all this
inside things for the argument okay so
you can't really sort of take it out or
factorize it that kind of thing it's not
straightforward
okay for instance this is definitely not
just this okay if only life was so
simple
okay so we're gonna have a look at these
right but I'll try and get you a long
way to wire so the first thing to think
about is exact values exact knowledge
now few trig functions sine cosine 10
okay you learn a set of exact values for
different angles right what are the
angles you learn it for okay we actually
stop zero okay and then the first one is
30 and then before 60 is 45 okay then 60
and then 90 okay five values okay now
there's a few different ways to remember
what the exact values oh okay so I'm
going to teach you
number one the one I learned when I was
in year 11 and the number two one I
learned years later which would have
been useful to me in year 11 but I
didn't get to it until I was actually
universal so maybe I'll be useful to
what's the first way okay
draw two frames and maybe you're
familiar with this one one of them
should be isosceles they should both be
running
do you ask in you I'll and as some on
this skinny one okay what do you do with
these okay
um they're both right-angled yeah so in
these two triangles I can put all of
these angles in and then get some of the
sides out of them through my fingers
okay so this one me the thinner one okay
because the aim is a different we call
this small 130 and the other 160 because
it's something that you now what's
required in here is that you have to
remember one ratio the first one okay um
the easiest one most people tend to find
this sine theta sine theta which is
equal to because it's a simple fraction
it's the one without on the one without
Squared's okay you remember by this
point I think it was in power into your
head enough that sine is opposite I have
happiness right so there's 30 opposite
on hypotenuse okay
and it takes pretty well please short
space of time to work out one-third
sizes which is root 3 okay with that
triangle you can work out sine cos tan
for 30 or 60 okay any of the different
combinations okay examine tan 60 10 60
tans opposite over adjacent right socket
are so tan 60 is root 3 all in one happy
okay you can rinse and repeat for any
kind of ratio if you like with 30 or 60
this one of course is the other one 45
that's why I told you how to be are
sausages because equal angles okay now
if I've got equal sides here and I make
those both equal one
then my hypotenuse will be okay and so
from here you can get sine 45 and close
45 right they're both equal to 102 and
of course you get tan 45 which is one
all right by the way don't forget sine
cosine right for instance sighing who
already wrote down sine theta is equal
to 1/2 you can see if I went from 60 and
did say cos 60 okay so that's going to
be adjacent on hypotenuse so call us 60
the sequence will huff and I could
reverse it as well sine 30 cos 60 you'd
be equal cos 60 in sine 30 would be
equal okay because that comes back to
what cosine stands for right it's an
abbreviation
it stands for complement sighing you
guys know what a complement is right as
opposed to a comm compliment as yeah
that's a nice haircut
right a complement in maths means and
adds to 90 right so if you've got these
two adding to 90 then you have the same
ratio they are the same ratio okay this
is the way I learn right so more or less
at the start of every senior maths exam
the first thing I do after reading time
is over as I just draw these two
triangles okay but another way i sir
I want you to take your hand and put it
down on your page and then draw an
outline around them don't my fingers
look that bad to you oh it's pretty
realistic to me okay now um what I want
you to come here okay is on that one the
par don't you read this some of this
will be very mysterious at first but it
all work out for the square root of x
okay then on the fingers right five
fingers on each hand I want you to put
the five angles okay so over here I've
got zero this scene is before by the way
who sings really no okay well I suppose
that's what happen to me just just my
tía to show you people this in your
grain mines would explode okay
so here you go you got that you got that
drawn in okay now this is my this is my
left hand at the moment okay because
this is my left hand all right all right
supposedly I'm done looking at this way
okay so I want you to whichever hand you
draw on maybe republic we got the same
one as me okay I want you to hold up the
same way your page is really okay I have
forgot one more thing on here I want you
to draw two arrows one coming from the
right and one coming from the left the
left one should say sign and the right
way should say close okay all right now
here we go if I want to work out the
side of cosine of any of these exact
note here's what you need to take your
hand and you say well which angle do you
want which I mean well let's do 30
because we already know if there's lots
of them oh right okay I'll take thirty
thirty is my index finger so I want you
to put your index finger down you did
that you managed okay so now what if you
got oh you got what have we gone okay on
the right hand side I've got one finger
one finger okay so that means that sine
30 is the square root of one finger
finger on soup square root of wine is
one sign that it's a huff okay on the
left hand right hand side I would call
is 30 about three fingers over here okay
so close that he is root 3 on 2 is it
okay alright so that was 30 weeks let me
give you another one just to try okay
let's do let's do 0 okay this one this
way is better because you can do this
with 0 and 9 in which you can't do
the triangles okay I put down my thumb
for zero okay so what's sine of zero
well I have no fingers on the left of
the finger up or down right so sine zero
is zero or two which is zero okay but
cause of zero is how do you think is
that I got to the right because I have
four right
so cos of 0 is 1 2 3 4 root 4 which is 2
right on too close of 0 is 1
let's do one more okay okay so I want to
do 45 degrees okay 400 degrees sine of
45 what is it it's root 2 on 2 root 2 on
2 root 2 on 2 that's one on root 2 isn't
it is to get a factor of 2 and of course
because I got the same number of things
on both sides sigh 45 5 45 and cos 45 on
the same that make sense and I could
keep going if you want but my fingers
are cramping so I'm stopping okay so hey
going that's kind of handy you don't
need to draw triangles did you get it
and yeah I seriously didn't I don't I
think actually what's better about it is
at 0 and 90 now what's my point
why not use that as an in for looking
that trig expansions okay here's my
first reason I'm gonna give you another
one my first reason is if you just put
these exact values okay I can't really
do much with anything that's outside of
those values even if they're nice new
combinations of those things which I
know ought to have an exactly right or
things like cars of say 15 right or any
other combination okay if I take 30 plus
45 or 45 minus 30
okay because these are those five values
you're just stuck get your calculator
out
good luck
but we treat expansions if I can
actually write this as something meaning
okay turn it into something I can
actually work with in exact terms I
would be stuck with a decimal anymore
okay I can actually get something exact
this is my first reason you can actually
expand what you can do with your exact
values okay
and secondly which I push it up here's a
time to go to but actually in real life
the tree functions that govern real life
and things like acoustic sound okay
communications which is electrical
signals anything which are oscillates
and waves around okay they all have lots
and lots of things in there things
aren't just nice and neat you've got one
thing in there okay work out your value
okay you've got lots and lots of values
in there lots of variables lots of
actual functions sine of sine of cos of
this right it's a straight complex I
need some way to break it apart okay so
that's what treating stations is about
right